Apple has just patented their work on
the next generation iPod Touch 8 but
it's not what you expected yes it's a
set of airpods with a built-in display
now I know it sounds crazy but it's
actually quite genius and it's not just
me making this up Apple's own patent
images for this new products prove it
and I'll be showing and explaining why
it actually makes sense in this video so
let's get started this right here is an
article from Mac rumors that which just
posted earlier this morning showing that
apple is researching an airpods case
with a built-in interactive touchscreen
and this image right here perfectly
explains what I imagine it'll look like
as you can see you have the album art
you have touch controls for media and
the volume all built in with an
always-on display and this was actually
filed by Apple in September of 2021 and
published last week with the US patented
trademark office so apple is a actually
working on this according to Apple's own
words they're saying that there is a
need for a headphone case device that
can control operations that are
traditionally associated with headphones
an example of playback controls changing
audio sources changing audio output
modes Etc and there's a further need for
a headphone case that can also convey
the information to a user through
haptics and or this
devices like this one and this right
here is just one image out of many
showing the airpods pro going into an
airpods case with a display right over
here and the best part is that Apple
suggests the case could have additional
processors and memory modules that would
allow it to carry out specific
instructions that are traditionally
associated with smartphones computers
and other connected devices so hinting
at basically a standalone device that
can open things like phone app mail
messages camera calendar weather maps
and more on your airpods and here you
can see the interactive display on the
case working with the earpods and
another source device now the place
where we actually saw a lot of these
images is from
patentlyapple.com where it shows off the
Touch display with the earpods case with
a user interface all working together we
got some images right over here but the
interesting thing is that we also have
patent images showing that you can
squeeze the airpods case to trigger some
kind of app command like switching
between different audio modes like let's
say noise cancellation or transparency
mode just by squeezing the case itself
of course we have messages right here
replies we have the weather app radio
app and a bunch of other things
including audiobooks and even Maps now
I've got to say that right now Apple's
airpods are absolutely amazing and
they're doing very very well in sales
but there's just one major problem
that's in the way of Apple targeting a
massive market for the airpods and
that's the fact that you need another
Apple device like an iPhone to use the
earpods and the major setback for apple
is that there are many teenagers
pre-teens and maybe even younger kids
who don't have iPhones because the
parents rightfully believe that they're
too young to have one and that's is what
made the iPod Touch so special in the
past it was a budget device you can get
for your kids it was safe for them to
use to listen to music and everything
else and it wasn't actually an iPhone so
it was the perfect device but now of
course we don't have one so why not
create a pair of earpods with a mini
iPod Touch built into the case itself
and before I explain how this is going
to work with giving these airpods touch
to a child and making them work there's
actually an awesome concept of this idea
that was created by H Keeley on
macramers forums over six months ago and
as you can see right here we have
stemless earpods with an airpods case
that's now black and it has a display
you can see it's showing the charge
levels right here you can even unlock
with ear ID which actually there's
patents for that as well you can see
there's album art media controls you fit
in songs onto the case itself with
built-in memory as you can see right
here you could choose your different
amount of storage space you can actually
switch between noise reduction
transparency spatial mode right here you
can switch and AirPlay to different
speakers you have the airpods level
where it's too loud and could
automatically bring it down you also
have different albums that you can
choose from nice interactive swipe
through it look at all this you can have
apps like YouTube music Spotify podcasts
you have your ebooks and maybe even make
a phone call with Wi-Fi or 5G you could
even have background sounds which I
think is a great idea by this Mac Rumors
poster and live translate that is
absolutely genius you choose your
different language maybe even some
health sensors the level of your noise
cancellation you have different settings
independent from the iPhone ear tip fit
test
voice memos right with your earpods of
course you have Siri and find my so if
you lose one of the buds you could
actually find it using the airpods case
itself and some of the stuff that he's
showing off is actually shown within
Apple's own patents that just came out
and don't worry I'm gonna get into those
images especially the ones that show
that Apple has the iPod touch as the
inspiration for this product but I
imagine this to work for kids and teens
by working similar to how the Apple
watch works with family setup where you
can buy your kid an Apple Watch SE with
cellular and you can set it up for them
and they don't even need an iPhone it's
a standalone device where you can have
location tracking messages calling other
fun apps and even music loaded onto it
and then on the other hand the Apple
watch is still a great product for
adults who want to set it up with their
iPhone and use it for everything else so
it works for both markets and I imagine
the new airpods touch to work exactly
the same way we already know that
Apple's airpods Pro 2 have the H2 chip
the U1 chip and Bluetooth 5.3 builds in
all they will need to add is Wi-Fi
connectivity into the airpods case
itself to be able to receive iMessages
and connect to Apple music do updates
everything else your kids would be able
to download music onto the earpods touch
themselves with the included internal
storage like imagine just 32 gigabytes
would be enough because that's what
comes on the Apple watch models and they
could still fit a ton of songs onto it
now what if Apple makes a cellular
version of the airpods touch just like
they did with the Apple watch SC you
would literally have an esim cellular
plan that you can connect and stream
apple music anywhere you go get text
messages from anywhere everywhere right
on of the earpods case itself now the
only problem with that would be battery
life but again the apple watch SE has
cellular as well so this would be an
awesome idea now here is finally the
proof of Apple envisioning this product
as an actual iPod Touch replacement
check out the official patent images
from the patent listing itself as you
can see you have media controls but
check this out they showed off an actual
iPod click wheel or scroll wheel where
you could literally stroll with your
finger just like you did on the original
iPods and iPod Touches and it would
adjust the volume you could see
clockwise changing the volume and then
as well you could just switch it from a
swipe like that absolutely insane that
brings back iPod memories here they're
showing off going through an audiobook
application where you can go back 10
seconds go forward 10 seconds and even
getting turn-by-turn directions with the
maps app so all of that basically proves
that apple is envisioning more than just
a simple display that shows a little bit
of things on it there's a lot of things
that you would be able to do with this
new airpods touch and I believe it would
make the most sense as a standalone
device with family setup just like you
can do with the current Apple watch that
way it opens it up to a huge Market of
teens pre-teens and younger children who
would love to have some nice air pods
but they don't need another iPhone or
other device to actually use and control
it and play the music that is a huge
value and parents don't have to worry
about buying two different devices air
pods and an iPod or airpods and an
iPhone or a Mac anything it's all built
into one I think that's a genius idea
who knows if it's actually going to come
to light because Apple does a lot of
different patents in and a lot of them
never show up sometimes it takes years
but if it does come I think it is going
to be an awesome product so let me know
what you think down in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed this
video click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign
[Music]